You dead? Okay.
Oh my god- OH MY GOD-
NoOooOOOooo
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome
back to Resident Evil 2 (Remake)
Don't mind me looking around like a freak for a second there.
We're back with Resident Evil 2! So, where did we leave off?
I have no idea.
I'm in the pervert's room!
I'm in uhh... Herbert Pervert's room.
I'm in the asshole's room.
I'm in the douchenozzle's room.
I'm in the dickmongerer's room.
The room of- The realm of shit and tits.
It's bad it's not good- Let's read this.
Oh I'm sure
Taxidermy Log: "Pleased with how it turned out,
but I'm getting tired of working on these puny things.
May be time to move on to more challenging animals."
"I nearly came when I sliced its yellow bel-"
*Disgusted Sounds*
MY EYES!   MY EYES!   MY EYES!
Burn it! Burn the game! Burn!
BURN THE GAME
*Wailing*
"I still smell of wild beast. This is the life."
"The specimen's body is soft, sweet, and white all over.
And it's all mine. Forever."
A pig.
Oh God ooGH
*More crying*
I wish I were dead
I wish I was dead.
Help! Who are you?
Help..Help! Who are you?
Nice penis!
AUHhh
Wait what the hell-
I thought it was moving for a second there.
Ok there's gotta be something in this room-
else to discover.
I just don't know what it is yet.
There's something else, there's a heart door
but I don't have a heart key.
Um here- Woow! That's big-
That's real big! Is that the Siberian tiger that you almost-
*Disgusted noises*
Kill it. Kill it! Kill it! Kill it!
KILL IT DEAD
Its fine
Hello
Hi. Hello
How are you?
Good. Hello! I'll take that, thank you.
Hello. Hi!
HO bear you look happy!
Oh hello
Oooh I don't have electronics parts.
I need those- And a dodo! That seems odd.
Ok whatever
This guy sure liked to collect things
Re- * B   U   R   P *
-Shop Letter: "From your description regarding the electronic lock
on the door [on] the police['s]... office, it sounds like something needs replacing...
Power panel parts... east storage room...clock tower"
Ok got it
Alright something bout the clock tower
HEY!
THAT LOOKS LIKE A KEY
That looks like it has some kind of a key in it.
Heh-heh-heh-heh-heeey
Well would ya look at that, I've been looking for that forever.
I didn't know it was exclusively to the Claire part.
I had a sneaking suspicion that it was exclusive to the Claire part, but-
I did not know for certain.
Ok what else is here? Nothing here, nothing in this hallway.
There's still something in here apparently.
Ooh, but what is it? Is it in the butt of one of these taxidermies?
Alright whatever I can't find it.
I'm gonna put the gratuitous amounts of gunpowder away.
And I'm gonna put this away because I don't THINK I need that.
And we're gonna go with what we got thus far.
Ok.
So let's unlock the heart door.
And see where that's gonna lead us.
I'm sure it's gonna be great and I'm really gonna be happy
About whatever it is.
I just- The more I learn about this guy-
OOOOOH
No way we're here!
No way!
That's were that door lead?
Ohh, that's so cool!
Okaay.
Good!
There was another heart-
up-  up-
up- UP-
up- UUUP- stairs, ok-
Don't know why that was so difficult.
There's another heart that was upstairsies.
I think. Yeah, I definitely remember there being something like that.
One of these days I'll board some stuff up.
But today is not that day.
Alright so somewhere in here.
Now are you guys still waiting on me, the answer is yes.
The answer is very yes.
Ok I know-
I knew
I knew it.
Ok hey listen listen
How are you not going down
*Sigh*
Sack of shit.
Ah! Fucking oh, I didn't want to waste that.
That's not what I wanted to waste. Ok whatever, I guess that's how we're doing this.
Kaboom
Alright are you dead or are you just feigning- You're feigning death.
Oooo
kay
Hey big guy.
No? Come on. Ok you know what?
I don't like you.
Oh come back where you going why're you hiding?
Where did you just go, did I blind you?
Did I really just blind you? Alri-AWWW that's what I thought
Get. Rekt. You piece of shit.
I just don't like you.
Here's a thing about that, I just do not like you
So don't even try me.
I shouldn't waste those but I was just feeling a little bit disgruntled.
And when I'm feeling disgruntled
I do things that are a bit rash.
But you know I'm me, I'm always leaping to conclusions.
Alright, um, what was through here first
Okay, that's locked
C'est la vie...